hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
right now climate protesters disrupt
Barclays annual general meeting calling
on the bank to stop funding fossil fuels
more than 100 people are killed as heavy
rains lead to flooding and landslides in
Rwanda
a warning that the government scheme to
replace gas boilers with heat pumps may
not be able to keep up with demand
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now climate protesters have
disrupted Barclays annual general
meeting to call on the banking giant to
stop funding oil and gas projects they
disrupted the start of the AGM in
central London with their own rendition
of stop by the Spice Girls
[Laughter]
well the protesters also quoted
Shakespeare prompting the Barclays
chairman Nigel Higgins to tell the
protesters to shuffle off
[Music]
we want to shuffle you off can you be
Shuffle out
right now that footage was filmed by our
business reporter Sarah Taft McGuire who
joins us now
um Sarah thanks so much for talking to
us so what was happening there
essentially as you heard numerous varied
protests throughout the AGM by a range
of groups and it wasn't just a
Shakespearean and Spice Girls Renditions
which you you heard there there were
other individuals who at various points
in the hours of the AGM stood up and and
called on the bank to Halt its
investment a new oil and gas projects
that you know after the minutes went by
there were sounds of groans being heard
in the audience but it wasn't just
protests that that were you know that
were featured as part of of the AGM and
there were also a huge number of large
number of questions asked in the AGM and
climate also really dominated the
questions that Barclays board Executives
were being asked more than a dozen
questions were asked to Nigel Higgins
the Barclays group chairman and they
were asked a range of things again by
range of groups including money
Rebellion Bank track
um all share action many share activist
groups were asking questions about
essentially uh Barclays climate records
they were aspect deforestation as I
mentioned new funding for oil and gas
specific fracking projects nuclear
funding of of of dairy and and beef
projects so client Barclays climate
records really under scrutiny and under
the sustained attack from a varied uh
range of climate activists okay Sarah
thank you so much
well let's have a look at today's other
news now and in Rwanda at least 109
people have died after Heavy Rain
triggered flooding and landslides in the
western North of the country the state
broadcaster says authorities are still
searching for survivors trapped in their
homes with the river sebaya bursting its
banks parts of East Africa are
experiencing heavy rainfall at the
moment with at least three people
drowning in floods last week in
Southwestern Uganda
meanwhile the un's World Meteorological
organization has warned that the
likelihood of El Nino a complex climate
pattern that can disrupt normal weather
across the world is increasing new data
suggests there is a 60 chance that El
Nino will develop by the end of July and
an 80 chance it will do so by the end of
September scientists say it would likely
lead to a new spike in global Heating
and increase the chance of
record-breaking temperatures
and defense lawyers for the former chief
executive of Audi say he has agreed to
confess to his role in the diesel
emissions scandal in exchange for a
suspended sentence and a million pound
fine Rupert Stadler was charged in
Munich in 2020 after Audi and its
partner group Volkswagen admitted using
illegal software to cheat on emissions
tests Mr Stadler had previously rejected
the allegations
now the government's Flagship scheme to
replace gas boilers with heat pumps
could run out of money by next year
which would be well before it is due to
end the boiler upgrade scheme gives
households up to six thousand pounds to
install air or ground Source heat pumps
but analysis by the energy and climate
intelligence unit suggests that if heat
pump installations continue at their
current rate demand will outstrip the
available funding now it says the number
of heat pumps installed under the scheme
over the last few months has risen by
about 10 percent on average month on
month it says if these rates continue as
many as 150 000 heat pumps could be
installed in the first three years of
the scheme but there are just 90 000
vouchers available in that time meaning
it may well be over subscribed while I'm
joined Now by Jess Ralston energy
Analyst at the energy and climate
intelligence unit just thank you so much
for talking to us so do you think this
is actually going to happen
well it's difficult to say at this point
obviously we're actually still fairly
early on with this scheme and even
though it was billed to start in may
last year it actually didn't really get
underway properly until November and
that was when the installer portal was
launched and actually advertisement of
the scheme you know the government
investing in advertising it so that the
public know it's there that didn't
really start until this year and so it's
possible that we could see growth
actually rise from where it is today how
does it actually work this scheme
but what happens is you do a first
assessment with an installer who will
come around to your house and say if
you're suitable most homes tend to be so
they'll come around and give you a quote
and the installer really is essential
part of this scheme you know they deal
with um the government in terms of
getting the voucher paid back and all of
that and so what the installers are
saying is actually it would be helpful
to have greater long-term certainty
about this scheme and other clean heat
schemes the government did commit to
extending the boiler upgrade scheme
until 2028 um at the end of last month
but they're still calling for more
certainty about what's going to happen
after that and given we're in 2023
already you know it's only five years
until the extended scheme comes to an
end so they're looking for longer term
certainty how much does it cost to
install one of these heat pumps
well what we're seeing is really
interesting in the UK at the moment
we're seeing a bit of a price War
um with heat pumps obviously they're
quite new to the UK but there's over 20
million installed across Europe and over
half of households in Norway for example
already have heat pumps but over here
they're much nearer you know we've had
gas boilers for a long time the north
Seas running out of gas and if we don't
start transitioning away from gas we're
going to end up imposing more from
abroad so the thing is with heat pumps
they run off electricity and and at the
moment British gas are offering them for
as level as 2 500 pounds and I think
octopus at
299 pounds but it might be the other way
around either way
um it's less than three grand for a heat
pump and from those two companies at the
moment so at the moment it's working it
may be a bit late or it may have started
a bit later than expected but it is
working
um with the data that you've got what do
you think the government should do to
make sure that it Carries On
but what the industry is calling for is
that longer term certainty
um out until 2035 that's when the
government have said that they want to
phase out and fossil fuel boilers all
together so the industry is looking for
longer term certainty beyond the boiler
upgrade scheme and and the installers
are also looking for help uh to retrain
and upskill so that they can install
heat pumps there's over a hundred
thousand gas boiler Engineers gas safe
ones at the moment and transitioning all
of those people across to heat pumps the
industry's saying you know we can do it
we just need help in order to do so and
that comes in in the form of investment
into new training schemes new training
centers and but also just a longer term
Clarity on what the policy is going to
be around heating because at the moment
it's a bit of a mixed bag okay Jess
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you so much for watching that's
all from us today join us again on the
daily climate show same time tomorrow
[Music]